large uninterrupted blocks of time you
have to schedule if you are a creator
blocks of time that are at least two to
four hours or more in length
no Frankenstein monster of 20 minute
breaks and ten minute breaks combined
into three hours will have the value of
an uninterrupted block of three hours we
all have the same 24 hours in the day if
you don't have time you don't have
priorities you need to be able to sell
whether it's Kickstarter whether it's
New York Times whether it's your local
newspaper you need to be able to
communicate effectively and so which is
why when entrepreneurs ask me for books
to read outside of business books I say
on writing well bird by bird all books
on writing improving communication David
Ogilvy Ogilvy on advertising
study print ads where you have very
little space I think those are all very
very effective the best entrepreneurs
I've ever met are all good communicators
so the one perhaps one of the very few
unifying factors they're exceptional
communicators practice is the only way
to get better at communicating so one of
the things that I did four years is any
time I bought something I would identify
the ad the phone call the print ad the
the offer whatever it was that made me
decide to buy it and I would either cut
it out or record it put it into Evernote
whatever it might be and save it so I
had a record of everything that I bought
and why I bought it and then I could go
back and review it and I'd be like oh
looks like I fell for this this and this
not a bad way it looks like this tipped
me from yeah or not interested - yeah it
spent five fifty five hundred five
thousand dollars around yeah I save all
that everything that works in sales has
been done already so just keep track of
the crap that you buy or the awesome
stuff that you buy and decide what was
the trigger what push me over the edge
and then just sell the people like you
that's what I do it's really easy I make
a lot easier than trying to guess you
just watched two amazing clips from Tim
Ferriss take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think of
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]